so represent black and say We'll
conscious you that if this is being
recorded everyone who watches YouTube
will know your your uh summer vacation
spot so
um
so anyway let's I know your time is
precious and Melissa should be here soon
why don't we just get started uh we've
already had one session on this so this
is uh
uh
study committee subcommittee on um
interim study for HB
1295 here at 2 o'clock
and that one is the measure requiring
reports
concerning school policies on classroom
recordings and in classroom observers we
spent
um a good period of time already uh I
know uh I wish it was not here and I
guess uh Julius wasn't either but you've
had a chance to look at the the YouTube
um as have others I could tell by
looking at the number of views so anyway
we've already talked about this quite a
lot so let me just summarize again and
then we can discuss and then hopefully
get a motion of some sort uh and then
we'll do another one at three o'clock
so this is uh as we said before I know
I'm repeating myself mostly you all were
here before modeled on the gifted
student bill which is not a law and all
this the intent of this measure is is
simply to uh as was the case with um
HP 321 the gifted bill
simply solicit reports from districts
for doe to and I think attorney Fenn was
here for the previous uh session as well
so I know this is uh old news to her as
well uh simply uh
requirement to submit reports for again
a best practices folder on policies
regarding uh classroom recordings and
classroom observers and some of this is
uh related to covet when so many schools
went remote uh when hybrid and some new
questions came up about uh privacy
issues and this is we've talked about
all this before so anyway without
repeating all that again that's the
essence of it simply asking for reports
for Best Practices folder so that we can
compare approaches on
uh
classroom observations whether in person
or remote so this quick summary and uh
the member is assigned uh Moffat leka
and if Linda can't be here and if and
I'd like to have emotion in some sort of
emotion and vote today because the clock
is ticking I have no problem if
if Linda doesn't make it or if Melissa
says she's on her way but if I have no
problem if if Dave wants to sit in for
uh
[Music]
I think she had put in an amendment
um
and I don't see him
oh wait to oh H
um because I think the
bill says school district and I think
her Amendment added charter schools
sure I remember when this first came
through that she had an amendment
actually it's one that I like personally
and um Wanted to integrate for our
purposes today in the chair is in the
house as well
um
we're looking for I'm looking for this
being an interim study committee nothing
that happens here will is going to
become
um in the statute process all this is
going to be is is actually like the
gifted bill which went to interim study
talked about it
um and recommended the concept and then
in subsequent term uh the bill came back
and reflected new language that came up
from the interim study work so for our
purpose to say we're not gonna we don't
need to we probably shouldn't try to get
into amendments it's not what this is
about as I see it
this is simply about giving uh some sort
of a yay or nay on the uh the bill so
that we can pass that on to the full
committee and then if there is similar
legislation submitted next year uh you
know the work from from this
subcommittee will be useful in in coming
to uh
you know discussion on the future bill
so Mike do do we have an example of um
of what the um in classroom Observer
policies are and what the in classroom
audio visual streaming and recording
policies are or look like
well good question I I don't have that
and again I'm gonna hearken back to some
uh earlier
uh measures like the gifted build
um
what we finally try to tried and
succeeded in avoiding with that bill
interim study is uh getting too much
down into detail in the weeds in the
interim study process yeah so that
that's that's not really what I'm asking
for what I'm what I'm trying to get a
better understanding of and maybe
um attorney Fenton can help shed some
light light on this I I don't know if we
heard I don't I don't have my my notes
with me from the um from the hearing on
this but but I think I recall
um they're potentially there being a
question about whether
um whether this could um
have implications on on school safety
student safety faculty safety and um and
certainly seeing at least examples of
what these policies look like might help
us better understand what what possible
impact uh they might have but maybe
maybe Diana's got up got had some info
information on on how these policies
could read on on student staff school
safety okay before I Look to attorney
Fenn
um speaking with myself here what I
don't personally want to see us get
wrapped up in is getting into the
examples and details and debate about
this aspect or this policy of that or
whatever the the issue here is in very
broad simple general terms can we ask
districts to regardless of what their
policy is to Simply share what is
already public policy we're talking past
each other Mike I'm not I'm not saying
that that I'm not I'm not implying that
that this legislation should should
establish a framework for such policies
but if if if it's common that these
policies contain information that
um that that could impact school safety
student safety staff safety
um
in any way then I think we should
understand that as a committee and and
take that into consideration whether or
not
um this is recommended for future
that's all I'm saying I'm not saying
that that it needs to
say what's in or what's out of these
policies but if it's common that that
Apollo that these types of policies
would contain information that could
impact student or school or staff or
faculty safety they I think we should
understand that
yeah thank you I'm trying to track uh
what you're saying and again uh
to repeat myself I guess uh I just don't
see
our role as being to get into you know
details uh of which it sounds like
you're alluding to in terms of wanting
to see a model once we see a sample then
you know we can spend uh a whole lot of
time on the merits of whatever model you
talk about uh that's not what I think we
want to do I think what we want to do is
decide if if we want to have a
uh report requirement sharing public
information in one place again I I keep
saying as was the case who gifted uh
sure uh representative leckis
I think what the issue here is if a
school's policy is specific enough that
um that might be used by somebody say
how they video the hallways or where
they're videoing or whatever if it's
specific enough that and these reports
will be public presumably could somebody
use them
um this reports that are being submitted
to the doe could somebody use them to
break into the school to do whatever and
can do we we need to think about that
when we
suggest this that we would want a sort
of generic policy and and not something
specific enough that's going to go away
is that is that what you're
right okay
Mr chair thank you very much I just
recently met this past
two weeks ago with the infrastructure
commission which I also chair and we
were handing out Grant funds we're
working in conjunction with uh Jennifer
Harper's now gone from the Homeland
Securities director and there's a new
director over there I believe it's
Robert Buxton we also had president at
that meeting uh Eddie Edwards who is the
Deputy Commissioner of uh of safety
department of safety here in the state
we were handing out on the first round
of Grants here regarding safety security
in the school's access to schools
Communications in schools with outside
Emergency Services
we had to do that meeting in closed
session
we weren't discussing any of that policy
due to the fact we are talking about a
very sensitive uh area in schools right
now and also with Homeland Security how
they're looking at these applications
they had to do that in accordance with
their criteria and that criteria is
confidential
and so uh yes uh representative Luna you
bring up an excellent point
um you know we we cannot get into that
realm we can't go there
the schools are working on an issue
recall when we were looking initially
for the Emergency operation plans before
to doe there's concern from
superintendents and school
administrators that principles that by
submitting that are we releasing this
confidential information and we don't
know where it's going
um and and that was they were even
concerned in sending that stuff to the
data processing people at Homeland
Security
so uh this is very sensitive territory
and I I'm having some Deja Vu here again
uh what are you
what is what happened uh again years ago
the gifted Bill where we're wedded about
this what about this scenario getting
down the ways and that is not where uh
is a prime sponsor that's not what I'm
looking to get into or was looking to
get into this uh the purpose here today
is not to get into all these details and
scenarios our purpose as I see it is the
prime sponsor and the chair of this uh
interop study committee is simply to uh
recommend or not that the the concept of
having a best practice folder be
be put into place
um
as soon as attorney fem this year I know
that she's already spoken to all this if
I can ask Diana
um
do you mind coming up to where you've
sat many times in the past very briefly
so my again my question to Diana
is
simply
can the purpose of this is is to have a
central uh virtual folder if if you
would to centralize public information
all of these existing policies or
published policies so there's there's
there's no uh
uh
there's no need to as I see it to uh
take specials or replace special
safeguards for something that's already
public policy so anyway uh attorney Fen
um my question to you is if you could
speak to what you did the last time
about doe uh doing the same thing with
sure thank you for the question for the
record Diana Fenton from the Department
of Education to answer representative
luno's question I I myself am not
familiar with these policies I I am
making an assumption that school
districts have these types of policies
on their website available to the public
but I don't I'm not here to speak from
personal knowledge about that I know the
last time we were here we did talk about
that potential safety security issue
um when we deal with Homeland Security
issues and for example school districts
have to submit as representative Ladd as
well where they have to submit their
blueprints their safety plans
those that information by law is not
accessible under 91a so we cannot turn
those over to the public and and there's
a very valid security reason behind that
and they are housed with Homeland
Security it's not within the purview of
the Department of Education in terms of
this proposed bill in front of us my
testimony before my testimony today is
simply that based on the language of the
law that is ultimately passed
anticipating that it would mirror in
large part
what was passed as it pertains to
gifted students talented and gifted
students the department would set up a
similar format
by which it's electronic
um we do have a proposed template that
districts can use so that there is
consistency in reporting consistency is
always key
I think the definition is each district
can create their own definition of what
they consider gifted and talented and
then we put it in a folder that is
accessible
for people
I know that that was one of the concerns
from the Department when that bill not
this bill but that bill was for first
proposed is how this information would
be accessible what the department would
do with it and that was the Compromise
thank you much questions for attorney
Fen
um Bruno
so thanks very much
um
so
Donna our um
I was just trying to find a a link to on
the doe site to what um what are the
required School statutory required
School Board policies and I believe
from time on the board that that the um
that that there is a required policy for
audio video recording
um I don't know if it's the same as
what's being asked of here I don't
recall if there's a required policy for
in-classroom observers do you know if if
that's a required policy
the short answer is I don't off the top
of my head I know that there was a law
that was passed a few sessions ago that
talked about in classroom observations
and I think there's a notice requirement
affiliated with that I don't know if
there's a policy requirement
um so these are great questions too
blush out and it is at this moment in
time that I can say uh while being
recorded I did not bring my law book
today and I knew I forgot something so I
knew I packed my lunch and my laptop and
I knew I forgot something and that's it
so um I do know that there is a law that
talks about those in classroom
recordings but I think your point is uh
well made is figuring out the difference
between the two
and especially since covid those are
probably areas that get very modeled
um
from a district perspective
and and I think to that to that extent
if it's not a required School Board
policy then it could be an
administrative practice
um and which could contain
um sensitive information like like what
what Rick was was talking about that
hadn't been aired during a public uh
hearing
we I can't remember the number of years
ago when represent cordelli presented
his bill on recording in the classroom
which uh
caused a tsunami of concern from all the
districts and we got in the area of
special education services who's
qualifying confidential information we
got into the business of student
teachers that are are practicing are
doing their internship or whatever in
the classroom and and how do you do how
do you record that even with the special
service child
so uh I don't I don't have my folder
with me either today my my yellow book's
in there but that wouldn't help me my
folder would help me on this one but I I
think that this is an area that if we're
looking for you know a boilerplate
policies
I believe those are in place from the
school boards Association
and I've seen those but then what we had
this is where we had on that meeting
when Glenn got you know tripped up with
this same legislation and we had a huge
meeting over there with all districts
participating including folks from doe
and I can't remember which district it
was it's down where Terry wolf came from
and Bedford area and they had a
technician down there that was trying to
write this boilerplate for all school
districts that we could have that come
from there so that's my extent of it
without having my materials in front of
me I think the law was passed in 2016
maybe 2017. that's your your framework
but again I think there's the in-class
recording
law and then what districts have created
policy Wise from there and so if we
start with finding the law
then we can reach out to the school
boards Association and see what their
boilerplate policy is and then it would
be up to this committee to decide from
there where if at all they want to go
with what information they want to
yeah sure thank you the cordelli bill
I've heard a lot about that uh chairman
Ladd and this is not anything like that
at all uh again uh for the umpteenth
time
um the gifted Bill the intent of that
was to raise awareness of a situation in
some districts where some gifted
students weren't being uh
taken care of
so now that the gifted bill is law every
District it's on their radar screen and
by having to submit a report to doe that
requires the districts to at least you
know look at the issue there's no in
that case or neither in that case nor
this case is there any policy
requirement or spending mandate all it
is uh in this case is asking for uh
public information to be shared with doe
now as we're gifted the intent behind
this uh candidly is because we're in a
whole new world like years and years ago
the worst there was no such thing as
zoom we're on YouTube right now
so because largely because of covid when
we have all these uh new uh scenarios
with hybrid classes and recording and
questions about if who's watching at
home and uh can somebody uh you know
record I mean his privacy issues there
my antenna intent is not to address
those at all other than to raise
awareness that that uh these are new
issues that need attention in the best a
good way if not the best way to do that
is to uh through the requirement of a
report to dle uh that to share good
ideas and if they if there is some
policy if some schools in this process
discover that they don't have policies
that are adequate then they can go to
this folder and see okay this school is
doing this and that's a good idea so we
can improve our policy by just comparing
uh what we have or don't have to what
other schools are doing via this Central
uh uh virtual folder if you will and
just like the gifted Bill very very
simple so I I know I keep saying I I I
Reckless heading down into all kinds of
details and so is Dave and uh not where
I want to go or we need to go you know
basically do we want to have a report
requirement for recording policies the
way we did we gifted or not hand uh
representative uh I was going to say
caught it representative Hall
okay um you keep saying and we all can
be as well as with the gifted case
do we know I guess an attorney do we
know how that has worked out do we know
like so if you're basing it on that
I'm assuming that that was very
successful and I don't think that that's
really the case because it hasn't even
no that's that's what I'm saying but
basing on sure if we don't know the
effect of correct sure a good question
uh in a fair fair question a gift that
just became law so there's really
nothing yet to compare it to until the
schools have time to to uh uh in fact
just going into effect this coming year
right so it's uh uh right I mean it is
you know but again it's just a uh uh a
folder of uh a photo to collect policies
as simple as that uh yes uh
representative like us
so if we ask for the public policy would
that then
eliminate the issue of safety and all of
that because we're only asking for their
already public policies I don't know how
to word that
to to say you know
their General policy that like they
might even tell the parents or be on
their website or something like that as
opposed to their you know detailed this
is what we do for and we're just talking
about classroom monitoring
and
right
I mean hallway monitoring and that kind
of stuff anyways that's not even oh sure
I mean there's all kinds of really
interesting uh details and scenarios
that we that we could get into uh we
don't want to here but if this comes
back in some form next year somehow
someway there are a lot of things that
really do need some discussion and
perhaps stats you don't really know uh
but if we have if if the schools
can share whatever their policies are in
one place
um then that'll be a step in the right
direction
without a statutory requirement for
schools to
share their policies with doe
um
some schools I don't think would do
anything wouldn't do much or whatever
and yes this is called before why
doesn't Doh just uh issue a memo and say
send us your information
the implementer the perimeter of
statutory action shows that this is like
an important it's not just some memo you
know send this to your
you know kindergarten numbers this is
potentially very important and so it
rates I think uh you know some sort of
Statute to underscore that this is an
area that uh you know people need to um
pay attention to
well trying to get into details uh sure
representative Blissfield thank you
representative Moffett
um I wanted to ask
since not here before
um regarding the pot where we tried to
put some bills out there regarding
recordings in the schools and the
classrooms and you mentioned that there
were an array of people that came to
speak on it are we talking
administrators teachers and staff or are
we talking parents because I think those
may be two very different viewpoints on
this particular topic
sure another great question and and I'll
say the same thing they've said to other
uh points or comments that have come up
about
um you know who's this involved as role
of parents or whatever uh great
questions there's so many great
questions that need attention and uh so
that is something that would come out of
this if uh at some point next year or
whenever uh
we have this requirement that schools
organize their policies their public
policies and send them to to doe
um because of the statutory requirement
I hope that helps somewhat yeah sure
no
I am curious still though who was it
that came that came out to those
meetings to speak to speak was it was it
school staff that don't want recordings
or was it parents that said my kids
won't be safe because from what I'm
hearing right now a lot of parents are
coming out and saying I want to see
what's happening in the school so I do I
do I would like to know if if anybody
knows that um that's number one and then
number two
um if you don't mind kind of unpacking
this for me for all of us when we talk
about
um what would this look like for example
you're saying that a school sending a
report can you give us a visualization
of how you think that might be broken
down what a report might look like I
mean I'm not talking like you have to go
through 12 Pages worth but you know just
a simplified table of contents what
exactly are you thinking
sure if you're asking me my vision of it
um
his attorney Fenn said again going back
to the gifted bill they did create a
template a helpful template to share
with the uh uh districts on how they
could submit whatever policies uh they
had in the in the gifted area so to your
question
um if this if some version of this
requirement this reporting requirement
requirement move forward uh I'm sure doe
would do the same thing they create some
sort of a template in this word that
they have an advisory or I think or
something like that that gives the
district's guidance in terms of how to
respond to a uh to a reporting request
um hopefully that helps a little bit
um
I know you're asking about for reporting
formats and what what might be in there
um
again
I think they could satisfy this by
simply
uh sending an email frankly I mean I
don't want to get too prescriptive
that's but I think that to respond to
the doe requests for a report on
recording policies and classroom
observation policies
they could simply send an email to a
designated uh person or whatever At Doe
with attachments and here's our policies
and you can file them simple as that
Mike um
we're we're talking two different topics
right here within this bill in classroom
recordings
and classroom observers right okay now
I'll take the ladder first the in
classroom observers
um that comes down oftentimes yes you do
have a boilerplate policy on that New
Hampshire school boards Association has
to stop but then how you implement
within the school is going to be not
necessarily a policy but an
administrative guideline or
administrative dictate in the individual
School for example when I was a school
principal in elementary school we had
the policy where we didn't want to see a
lot of parents in school the first week
of school
especially when we're talking about
young children they're trying to break
away from parents it was a lot easier
for the teacher much easier to manage
and to try to get that degree in
Independence we had to get the
socialization skills going
we also had it within our policy or a
guideline it was more like a guideline
for us to follow because it was
administrative in nature that we when we
were giving the Statewide assessment and
we've been giving that all over the
country for years we didn't have
visitors during that at all that was
when parents were not welcome
um so if we're looking for this type of
information that's certainly available
through the individual schools that can
be done through a survey easily and and
gotten uh but uh there there's then you
get into The Observers that come in and
want to see okay what is our social
studies curriculum really like I want to
see that class talk
well it was just yesterday at the polls
I was talking to the new math teacher
down at Rivendell uh that's uh fairly
Vermont and Orford it's Interstate
government district and I said I'd like
to see what you're doing in mathematics
he's wow I'd love to see it come in the
classroom I'm going to talk with the you
know the folks in the sixth grade the
seventh and eighth some middle school
and
um it's a result of our all of us
knowing that we've we've seen slippage
since covet in mathematics and our kids
who've been out are sometimes down five
months six months and they're learning
and we're having to try to address how
we're going to accomplish that my school
districts I say U23 is going through a
revision of the entire curriculum as a
result of that and purchasing a new
program that's more aligned with with we
hope to get the analytics done so we can
get find out exactly where the holes are
in mathematics but be it as I spoke to
some earlier geometry or enumeration or
or some other aspect of learning so that
we don't have to replace the whole thing
but figure out where our weaknesses are
so we can see the growth well he's
advised me that we'd love to see you
coming in the classroom and when when I
request to get in there and see that
from the perspective here we are in the
education committee looking they
welcomed us said you're welcome to come
in uh they they know that there's a real
good purpose to help growth and
Improvement uh now when you're coming
into to just look at it in terms of uh
are you teaching about George Washington
or Martin Luther King or whomever in
your history program or social studies
program Civics I think that's they
welcome that as well uh I think that
where the big concern would be is that
um if you're getting into certain
classes which are special service
classes uh you're getting the classes
that are involving some youngsters you
may only have two or three kids in there
or or you you we talk about
confidentiality on the youth risk
behavior survey and represent Beaumont
say you have a school less than 10 kids
you can figure out who's taking the test
just by the answers
you can see the names and all this stuff
too when you're in observing so they're
going to be that level of
understanding and confidentiality so
we're in an area that I'd love to see
some of the stuff that I mentioned
earlier about when and how are people
welcome into the building we certainly
don't want people not welcomed and I
think that's where schools are as well
but there's got to be some conditions in
there too and
so that part I understand I'm having a
hard time though understanding when
we're getting into the the boilerplate
stuff which we've gone through and
representative durardelli it wasn't just
one bill it was several bills it was the
first bill which we made the errors on
and the second bill which had to correct
the errors and
um and I know that for a fact that's
what the policy is in all the schools
right now because that was the you know
that went through a lot of discussions
through uh various groups and
organizations so
um I I think we're into a topic Mike
that's going to be it's very very
complex and I don't know if necessarily
a survey is going to give you everything
you want
um I think you'd be wiser trying to seek
out some of the stuff from the school
boards Association and find out because
next week so what just happened here is
the beauty of what the intent of this
bill is okay which I think is really I
think is really cool so uh chairman Ladd
uh got into all these areas that I would
love to to discuss and talk about uh but
that's not the point of this bill if
this if some version next year would
have moved forward from this bill what
would happen in District after District
would be because
districts and board members and
administrators and teachers and parents
um
would see that there's a need to to just
send a report to doe they would sit down
like we're doing here
um like Rick's and Dave and Alicia and
Melissa are you know
thinking about specific scenarios
um the beauty of this is that with no
Financial requirement no no spending no
policy mandated spending or financial
spending Mandate of any sort
um this type of discussion will flow
forth uh everywhere that would not have
happened otherwise and so holes and
there are a lot of holes in policies uh
the purpose of this bill is not to have
any policy mandate is simply to get this
on the radar screens of districts that
need to in this Brave New World with
with uh with the technology that it is
uh to address some of these issues that
Rick and others are thinking about but
that's not the point of this bill this
this measure is simply asking for a
report to Doe which will get it on
districts radar screens I know I'm
repeating myself but uh and again uh
this reminds me so much of the gifted
bill I keep going back to that but it's
it's the same uh concept and went to
interim study and and we get into Weeds
about what about this what about that
and and finally uh it came out of
interim study Mel voted for it and Mary
Gile and Barbershop you know it was very
bipartisan they and Dan Wolfe and uh and
we've we've finally real people realize
we're not getting into policy we're just
asking for a report that will be in
providing impetus for local discussion
where it needs to happen so but the
title of the bill says policy
I have it right here requiring reports
concerning school policies on classroom
recordings and in classroom observers
yes it's asking for a report of existing
public policies it's not mandating a
policy it's just asking to share what
you have in place
yeah
other others sure
thank you representative and you may
have said this earlier I apologize if I
missed it was there a specific situation
or experience that prompted you to move
forward with this bill
I I heard I mean I understand it's it's
similar to
um the gifted bill I understand that but
I'm just curious oftentimes I think
there's a personal experience or a
constituent may come forward and that
kind of prompts us to say you know what
you're right let's take this further
great question I understand the question
and yeah so what prompted uh people uh
to talk to me and for me to follow up
with this bill
um several things to one example would
be when there are remote classes in Via
Zoom or or whatever the platform is uh
you know privacy questions you know
people were saying so when students are
watching classes remotely uh and they
can they record it
um or not and you know who's going to
watch are they going to be uh you know
archived or what if the student
embarrasses himself or herself uh in
class that's remote that's recorded you
know uh I'm not saying what the policy
should be but you asked what was the
impetus behind uh Shining Light on this
is that help
and there's there's many many other I
could give that's one specific example
um in terms of uh classroom observations
uh I mean I was a classroom teacher you
know and uh we there were policies about
if a parent wanted to come in but what
if when I was a teacher they didn't have
these uh didn't have these things
so that without
suggesting any specific policy uh I
think there's a need to in terms of uh
classroom observations or visitations by
parents or whomever limiting it you know
uh can a parent uh
pull out this and record uh I don't know
I'm not saying that well they should
have said that's a local decision but if
if something like this moves forward
then you know it'll be addressed locally
where and it and it needs to be I mean
it's really important uh Rick and you
know asking for like a survey I've
already said this sure we could ask for
surveys but
um again to have something in statute
shows that this this is important that
this need to
they have some local conversations and
and uh share what works it doesn't work
any anything else well I I do know that
um you mentioned one point that uh it's
kind of interesting to me too is your
cell phone uh that is opening up a whole
Arena now of of uh opening at the
classroom to that and and I just talked
just the other day again with one of our
Junior High grandkids
and you know and he's really upset the
girls in the class can have the cell
phones the boys can't you know and and
of course that's coming from a Junior
High kid uh and uh some are using them
some are not and and so it it it's
different I guess in every school and if
you want to have some consistency within
the school that's up to that school
staff to sit down with their parent
advisory Council or with the school
board and try and figure that one out I
know there I've been in some schools
where they you know just don't let them
take their cell phones out during the
instructional phase of the class and I I
think that's what should be done you
know as a librarian you don't want
somebody in there messing with their
phone when you're trying to talk about
you know the literature you're trying to
you know the general you're trying to
get into so there are needs for common
basic policies in that Arena and and
that if this bill is going to gather us
that information I I applaud it yeah uh
because we do need to have you know I'm
sure teachers are looking for support on
this one as well well because it becomes
a disc of the primary discipline plenary
issue for them when they have to keep
saying to you know a little Deb over
here hey dad put it away put it away if
not you're going to go down see Mr
principal right here
um and and so but every school is
different on that you know
exactly like when you just said Thank
you and again when Rick was getting or
chairman ladders getting into the
scenario the cell phones I mean that's
really interesting and important stuff
that needs to be talked about I'd love
to debate it here that's not again I I
apologize for paying myself but I think
Rex helping now finally to shine a light
on this very simple simple intent of
this measure which is just to get an
important very pardon me very very
important uh uh
issue on the radar screens so that the
districts can have overdue discussions
some are ahead of others uh
send the uh would it be easier than Mike
to say here's a survey do you have a
policy or an administrative guideline in
your school regarding a use of cell
phones in the classroom are kids allowed
to have it they'll say I have to call my
parent my parents are going to call me I
have a doctor's appointment so that you
know and it's going to change during the
course of the day and I need to know
when that is
um so I don't want to talk about cell
phones in here today
that's reporting recording and all that
stuff as well yes and so that's the
beauty of this bill is is this What's
Happening Here is uh you know there's
discussions that need to happen and so
without getting into specific policies I
mean I have ideas about cell phones I'd
love to share that's not what this is
above this this is about uh providing an
impetus for this discussion to happen in
places where it might not have otherwise
representative Litchfield okay I might
move down a few seats I'm afraid to ask
you're getting passionate here I have a
question for you in a good way by the
way I I admire it
um my question to you is when you're
talking about this and you're talking
about these conversations that are going
to happen and and I can see the more
you're talking about I can see what
you're saying that there's there are all
these policies out there and really who
really does sit down and kind of put it
all together right they're just out
there you're right I'm in that policy
manual
um my question is where where do you
envision these conversations happening
would it be do you think at the at the
administrative level because if it is
behind closed doors I don't know how
much it would benefit the public or the
parents whereas if it was that let's say
a school board meeting I think that
would be really helpful actually so I'm
just curious sure sure another great
question is so where do I where do we
envision these conversations taking
place uh the answer is I'm not exactly
sure uh every district is every culture
every school has some real culture so if
this if some version of this uh next
year would come to this committee and
and uh and come out of this committee
asking for a report to doe then the
school districts the sau's uh would get
a memo or or a message from doe saying
please up by this date send us a report
uh sharing your public policies on
classroom visitations and recording
procedures whatever
so uh Melissa what what I think would
happen I'm sure uh whether it's as I
said before school board members parents
faculty administrators whomever uh
having a uh a meeting
um talking about cell phones and talking
about coming to class I I and out of
that locally uh there will be different
policies that need to be in place some
places are ahead of others in terms of
this braver world of cell phones and
zooms and and visits and recording and
privacy uh
so I just trust the localities to just
come together and have this discussion
and come up with policies that need to
be in place and if if some really
interesting uh if one District comes up
with some interesting uh
scenario that nobody else had thought of
then and they share that then then by
sharing all these things it helps
everybody to get to to better places to
come up with policies that work locally
sure am I missing something I mean we've
got
um we've got the School Board
Association where school board members
get together and talk about things we've
got the school administrators
Association that hold
um I think at least monthly meetings the
southwesters the different areas where
superintendents and Senior
Administration get together talk about
things have speakers to come in and talk
about certain things we've got
um there's principles Association I
believe where principals get together
and just two days ago or several days
ago he's you and I attended the special
education Administration Association
right so I guess I don't know what I'm
missing if if this is such a big issue
either at the school board level the
administration level the principles
level the special education level
um there seems to be lots of opportunity
for uh already for um um for for school
leaders to get together and discuss
things and figure out where how how to
how to proceed with it and really
understand what the impact is one of one
of the difficulties I'm having here Mike
is that is that we're not we're during
this study we're not actually hearing
from from you know people like Jane
Bergeron or Carl Ladd or Dean cascaden
or you know or you know or or you know
um
or others
um you know in this area and and and you
know I I you know I agree completely
with what with what Rick saying that
that this is a very complicated area
that that potentially affects and
impacts a lot of different things I mean
if I'm if I'm the parent of a special
education student
um I already know that in small
districts the department is protecting
my students identity from being exposed
to um to members of the community who
later on in March may be voting on
budgets and um
but I'm not sure that that this that any
of these policies would necessarily
protect my interests as a parent of a
special education student particularly
as it relates to in classroom
observation
um
um I agree that that that a lot of
conversation has to be had around it but
I don't think all of a sudden creating a
big pile of what's in place right now is
where that starts
um uh so I'm just putting it out there
that that I've got a lot of concerns
about uh about accumulating information
in policies that may or may not be
already required by the um by the by the
state and and I I mean all right I'm I'm
not going to be a I'm not a fact witness
to the education committee none of us
really are supposed to be that but but I
think at least in many of our
experiences on school boards in
administration realize that the school
boards Association has a lot more model
policies than are required by the by the
state of New Hampshire so um so I just
want to leave it at that that I think
there's there's sufficient concern she
sure and to your point about you
mentioned Carl Ladd or the different
associations and all these the folks and
and structures that are in place uh with
that
what would this do to that again uh for
the empty time I go back to the bill of
the law that this is modeled on which is
a gifted law I will tell you that many
many many schools and we'll find out
better as this information comes in
we're doing little or nothing in this
area where they probably should and now
they will because there's a new statute
a new law that requires schools to pay
attention to an area that deserves
attention so some of the similar to this
I am conf I'm sure uh clearly is you you
keep saying it's very complicated and as
chairman laddin says it's complicated
well if it's complicated then there's a
need for localities to pay attention to
this and address some of these
complexities and come up with some
policies that uh clear I think clearly
need to be uh in place and through
statute uh that it means something you
know if education committee or the house
says this is important enough for us to
ask that you uh have a discussion about
it and share your policy uh in a central
location only Greg I think can come out
of communication and discussion
uh okay I I know it's almost three
somebody and I'm going to be looking for
the motion of some sort whether to uh
um support this concept for future uh
possible legislation or not
um but representative Moffett may I just
follow please
so the statute in question is RSA 189
and so again 189 colon 68 and it's
paragraphs 3 4 and 5 which deal with in
classroom recording
those were passed in 2015 and 2016
respectively so representative lad and I
got the dates right which is a miracle
that rarely happens on my part at least
I will not read it to this committee it
is rather lengthy but you can refer to
that statute and that's where it talks
about
the in classroom recording piece of it
sure and thank you and I point out that
2015-2016 predates the you know the
covid uh pandemic which
created some some new scenarios that
that you know some of us think would
need attention
um
it is a period of time now referred to
as before the pandemic right and then
there's during the pandemic and after
the pandemic so yes it is before the
pandemic yeah our post pandemic World
Mike
um
I've been visiting a number of
elementary schools just the other day I
was up at the Landau School prior to
that the number over in Vermont and I
was surprised when we walked over
Vermont and wanted to go into school
welcome you're in the school at the the
some of that pandemic stuff which we all
encountered that you couldn't even get
in a school you had to knock and leave
the stuff off for the kid outside and
they came to the door and greeted you
and I know there's a number of
disgruntled folks wanting to get in and
see instruction because it was a time of
Awakening for many parents here's what's
being taught in school and perhaps I
agree or perhaps I don't agree with
what's going on and so you want in
what is the policy for getting in and
observing a classroom might be what
we're looking at but it I I would say
that
we are returning and I I see it
happening right now today I can go to
many of the schools and I'm welcome
walking right in they say hello come on
in uh but if this happened uh last year
or the year before I wouldn't have been
welcomed in those schools so
I think we're going to be pre trying to
go back to what is so-called normal now
what is normal
um it may be different from school to
school and again it's about the
leadership in the building it's about
the school boards in that district and
how they what their attitude is uh and I
don't know if we're ever going to change
that
um do the fact we have elected officials
just as we are running those schools and
they're in charge of curriculum and
instruction and it's a local Affair it's
a local responsibility I think the way
we're going to really change access to
schools is from a local perspective a
parent saying I'd like to be able to get
in now if if that's the problem they
can't get in and observe a classroom
they're being told no you're not welcome
in there then we have we have a problem
we're going to have to address that so I
I'm I guess I'm really am because having
a difficult time understanding because
we do have policies I can remember that
hot debate we had back in 2015 and 6 16
and it went and went in two years and
um and now we're trying to find all
cakes submit your stuff so that we can
find out what's going on let's find the
best practices and share that with
everybody else is that not being done
through the school boards Association
now I don't know
but they do have these boilerplates
which they you know give everybody just
like the municipal government give
select boards and city councils that
information
yeah
sure okay
um it's kind of a three-parter so it's a
little disjointed um
I do want to say that I know this is
going to impact many different people in
their large concerns about the different
groups that will impact
um and I there's no other way to say it
so I mean it with the best of intentions
not in a combative way
but this has been posted the internal
study twice now and I wonder if would
adverse the impact or if groups if this
is a Hot Topic that they were that
passionate about it wouldn't they be
here right now or is that not typical
with an interim study that's my first
question
well it's a published a meeting
um and people I suspect there are a few
are probably watching now or can watch
later to hear our discussion on on this
so just that's my that's what I'm
wondering if it's that controversial we
might be able to address uh you've got
an interim study thing about meeting
where you sent out an email to
certain
um experts
to come to the meeting well we've done
that with a number of people that's what
that's yeah that's what we do and uh for
example we have an internal study that's
it's coming up
uh dealing with well it's not interim
study necessarily but we have the the
legislative oversight committee that's
scheduled around the block here and
we're going to be looking at uh
contacted doe and we know we're going to
have some very important people there we
did the same thing with teacher shortage
just a few days ago
um and we had uh you know not a full
house we only had maybe five or six
people in attendance there
um you're not going to get a lot of
attendance during interim studies it's
just the history of the planet here
summertime people are gone and we're
right now in September and you know most
folks right about now are back at school
picking kids up at the door
um it's it's uh that time of year when
we're going through a change I in the
past when we've had interim studies when
Pat's mineral studies and concussion and
all that years ago we had people coming
in and and participating because it was
an issue that was of concern and needed
address
this one may need address but I
certainly you know I don't see the
people attending it
um so and I know you have a couple
follow-ups uh again uh this is not
getting into anything that they glendid
years ago this is simply uh saying uh
we'd like to have you submit a report
with your public information I don't
want to don't not looking to get into uh
debates on specific policies or cell
phones or anything else uh again I know
I'm repeating myself and I apologize but
um I it it took it took a while with the
gifted Bill uh to go through interim
study and and I'm having flashbacks
because with their own study with gifted
chairman Ladd we were getting getting
all these questions about we gotta do
this or do that and about this or about
that and all that all that was finally
you know uh folks figured out uh it's
just a report and it's a report that'll
help people to pay attention to
something needs to be paid attention to
and so it's a lot and I I feel great
about that because I'm sure that all
kinds of good things are now going to
happen in terms of discussion about
neglected gifted students and in this
case it's the the same it's that's the
model for this uh if we ask for the
reports on this important area then the
local discussion will take place I to me
it's very very simple and uh
and I think we're making it more
complicated than than we need to but uh
unless you had some follow-ups right
I I just the other
um
comment that I had was I know that there
are several groups that probably could
address this principles right
um After School Board Association you're
talking about the superintendent
Association
um
you've heard me talk about this before I
have grave concerns and if we bring up
the New Hampshire School Board
Association because it is a lobbying
group they have hundreds of thousands in
their bank account I've researched it
I've seen it so if parents want to look
at those policies that they have we're
talking about they have a wide array I
don't know that we have access to them
as parents
um you have to pay what is it a couple
thousand dollars or it might even be
dependent upon your student population
per head
um to be a part of that I don't know
that as a general public we have access
to that
um I do like the idea of this
information being put in the centralized
location I've even had parents come to
me with concerns now that policies are
being stored electronically have these
policies been changed without people
even realizing it and whether it's valid
or not I don't know but I've had parents
bring it to me I like the idea of this
being on centralized I like the idea of
us kind of wiping the dust off and
taking a look at it
um I personally would like to um to
support representative Moffett in his
Endeavor so with that being said um I
would like to make a motion to move
okay is there a second
I'll second that
sort of a motion to recommend that we
move forward with the simple
recommendation that we support the
okay further comments discussion on the
motion
okay if not uh let me look at our
assigned folks here
uh representative leckis
yay or nay on that motion yeah
representative sodi you seconded it uh
yeah
representative Litchfield
yay
represent Tanner is not here but
representative luno is a no
representative Cornell
Interruption Paul no
and the chair uh Sports emotion
so thank you we have a four to three
recommendation to send to the full
committee thank you for the motion thank
you for your time
and
we have a second
interim study measure that we're
supposed to start at three o'clock so
maybe in five minutes let me see who's
on that uh
My Fit Hobson Lexus Litchfield will know
Ellison and huff so we're all here so
five minutes
or you want to start right now yeah all
right well
okay I have a request for two minutes uh
I'm gonna I'm gonna beat chairman lad
and say five minutes and but I but I
foreign
all right folks uh I think it was six
minutes whatever it was but uh I know
everybody's time is valuable attorney
Fen is in the house and will soon be out
of the house so we want to utilize her
expertise in experience in addressing
we need a policy on cell phones
I I I like that power off okay
but we need to decide you know who
manages the fund and uh what's it used
for so anyway so now we're talking about
uh HB
12 25. here it is
we just said 12.95 so we're talking
about
I have over here yeah 1676 and that has
to do with incentive grants so before
attorney Fenton leaves
um thing if you could uh it's a very
simple Bill you've been here before it
had a house a Committee hearing had
we've already had one interim study
hearing so you know the the Simplicity
of the concept we want to give doe a
fund to award achievement so if you
could speak to doe dealing with such a
concept
thank you for the record my name is
Diana Fenton I'm an attorney with the
Department of Education I apologize that
I have to make my Hasty Retreat for a 3
30 with uh the commissioner so we can
blame this on Frank uh as I blame all my
problems um
so
based on the concept that you have
explained to me
um it is a Department's position that
this could be best fulfilled by giving
the department rule making Authority
so
in technical terms you'll find
rulemaking in
541-a that's the statute that covers
rulemaking and when you look at the
various statutes that comprise education
some of them re require the department
to go into rule making so for example in
last session uh the bill for
co-curricular co-curricular activities
grants which I know representative
moffatt was a part of Representative
Mullen was a part of that bill it was
interesting that that bill gave the
department
um it was it wasn't mandatory rulemaking
it was optional and typically you see
mandatory rulemaking and it's in rule
making that the department flushes out
the details of the statute so a great
example of that would be Innovation
schools which was passed then a past
legislative session the department has
entered into rule making on that efas
the department went into rulemaking on
that but that rulemaking has to be in
the statute
we cannot we the department cannot just
arbitrarily go into rule making it has
to be
um
allowed for required in the statute so
if it is this legislative body's
intention to have a somewhat simple and
I use that word lightly simple statute
that gives the department authority to
create this program then in order to
facilitate that the department would
need rule making authority to to do that
and I'm happy to take any questions as
it pertains to that
thank you attorney fence so let me
follow up then you mentioned the
co-curricular bill which is now law I
was the original sponsor that and that's
another bill that went to interim study
if you were called it was initially
Unified sports spell went to interim
study uh whoops have Lang took it over
representative so it had a long journey
now it's wild so you mentioned
rulemaking to implement that with
through doe my question is
is the structure that is in place for
rule making that you used and that we
used to implement the co-curricular bill
can that same structure be used for this
proposed bill or do you need some new uh
language for rule making so the idea
behind the co-curricular bill was really
based upon the robotics Grant Bill which
passed before the pandemic
2019-2020 and so the idea behind those
two bills was to give the department
about fifty thousand dollars I know
fifty thousand dollars was the
co-curricular amount and then the
department would then disperse grants
upon application uh up to four thousand
dollars for for certain things and
co-curricular it's uniforms and
equipment
and there are certain criteria that go
with those grants and that is the school
districts can apply for it or they don't
have to apply for it so I think the
structure in implementing the idea
before us here would be a little
different it's it's not something you
would necessarily apply for it would be
awarded to but it would be awarded based
on certain criteria
and it's that criteria and the amount
and kind of the rules by which the
department would would work within that
would be facilitated best by rulemaking
another great example of when we used
our rulemaking Authority I always go
back to it was representative lad's code
of conduct bill the code of conduct law
is very brief
it just sets out four principles and
then it was a Department's
responsibility pursuant to rulemaking to
fully flush those principles out as to
what this looks what this looks like and
how the department will proceed uh
within those within that structure and
that's really what I if I understand
your intention that's really what this
legislative body is is requesting
and so it would be rulemaking that would
allow the department to act within those
rules and that way it's not arbitrary
that was very clear to everyone what the
rules are what the department looks at
what the criteria is it's not subjective
thank you so the 1676 is it came to us
uh it was a fiscal note uh I had to do
the million dollars
the some version of this manifest itself
and comes forward the next year
um
looking at what is the language in the
initial proposal
what I'm hearing is that you'd like to
see some better language that addresses
the need for
rules that Doe would need to see to
implement this word ever to become law
is that correct
the bill at least had better language re
rules
I think in order to facilitate the
intention of the bill the department
would need to create rules to facilitate
it and in order for the Department to
enter into rulemaking we need rule
making authority pursuant to RSA 541-a
in its simplest form
okay thank you and unless comment would
be depending upon who gets reelected or
who's in the mix next year and and what
if anything along these lines moves
forward uh you or doe would certainly I
would think be available to talk to
sponsors on coming up with the language
that
would help to move it forward from Doe's
perspective right absolutely
that's a comfort thank you
sometimes it's a comfort sometimes it's
not
questions uh represent Bruno thank you
Mike so um you know I know we haven't
had a whole lot of Opera well we've had
opportunity but maybe not much sex
success with uh putting forward or
working together in a bipartisan way to
to develop policies that that actually
have some stick-to-itiveness in the um
um you know in the law and obviously you
know the results in November as you were
alluding to will certainly have an
effect on on what happens next session
but uh I would I would offer that if you
were looking for some durable success
with with this that we consider
um uh reorganizing it a little bit I
think it's backwards
um I don't know how some districts like
Manchester are going to be able to
somehow magically do something that
improves student outcomes in such a way
that then they'll be able to get a fifty
thousand dollar reward I would suggest
that that the grant be based on
on school districts submitting an
application and a proposal and those
proposals be vetted by the department
and the winning proposals be awarded
fifty thousand dollars to improve
Student Success and um and you know I
think we could probably get more more
bipartisan support uh if it was
yeah I I hear you and and uh
um again I don't know if I'll be around
after this month or who's going to be in
the mix but which you describe uh is
intriguing to me
um I know attorney fensley is leaving
okay
um
yeah so to to what you just said uh
David yeah I mean uh that is intriguing
to me
if I think what we need to do today
is decide whether or not the the notion
of creating a million dollar fund or
whatever the the language and and uh
1676 is for a million dollars
we need and I'll be looking for some
sort of uh Motion in the in a rope on
uh
um
so that we can either endorse the
concept or the notion of uh rewarding
achievement
and then incentive to the full committee
and then and then see what out of that
we might try to put together for uh an
LSR
yeah so so um so I think you
misinterpreted what I suggested
um um what what I'm suggesting is not
rewarding achievement but actually a
competitive Grant process to encourage
achievement and so um so districts would
submit proposals saying here's what
we're going to do to uh to what what it
here's what we're going to do to affect
an improvement in student outcomes on
the and I forget what the I I was
looking at a second ago the standardized
tests or the the state um you know
assessment exam or graduation rates or
whatever you want to measure and um uh
and then it would be like I said it
would be a competitive
um uh Grant process the grant the grant
applications would be reviewed by the
department winners would be selected
um uh for awards and uh and then would
receive the award
um to be used to put towards that um uh
that initiative so the model you
described if if a proposal is put
together that has a metric and the
proposal that your school comes up with
says we propose uh to try these things
in order to improve our uh standardized
pick an assessment whatever yeah yeah
whatever representative Hopson I
actually met with some Folks At Doe and
Caitlin Davis had some ideas as to what
assessments
um they might recommend I I don't need
to get in the ways as to which
assessments but my question to you is uh
so my comment to you is what I'm hearing
is that
a proposal generated locally that had
metrics for improvement
were those metrics to be achieved then
they would be eligible for uh some money
no that's not what I said okay so what I
said is the proposal would would be
submitted the proposal would be would be
judged based on what the what whatever
the Department's criteria is for um for
improving Student Success the grant
would be awarded to those those winning
app like those those in a competitive
application process the fifty thousand
dollar Grant would then go to the
schools and then the school could use
that 50 000 Grant dollar Grant to fund
the proposal to um to uh to meet the
objective outcome okay so I think we're
we're getting a better understanding of
how we're looking at this so what I'm
hearing from you is
that you do not expect a metric to be
met in order for the the money would
come in in response to a good plan and
then they would get the reward the award
correct award is on the plan award to
fund the plan as opposed to a reward for
uh meeting a metric okay so all right so
the order of operations okay uh
representative
we've been kind of doing that all along
is giving money and hoping the schools
have a plan and use it and we gave a
whole bunch of extra money last year
specifically for them to be able to and
we asked for them to put in plans and
give reports and everything on how that
money gets used
you're putting that out there else could
you cite what that is because I'm not
aware of what you're connecting that to
what was the that at the end of the year
we did
um no that's there's the there's the
extraordinary needs extraordinary that
hasn't even started yet that hasn't
started right I'm just saying that we
yes we've instituted that this is a
completely different a completely
different focus and means of getting
change because what we want is
Improvement right and so according to
that we're giving money to the schools
and they're supposed to have a plan and
hopefully they will improve and this is
the opposite and it's intentionally the
opposite to say you improve we're going
to reward you for that and we've got the
one that you're talking about basically
I mean it's not a it the money's already
there it's been given for people to
improve
I think we need to have a multi-faceted
approach and this is one we haven't
tried yet we've been putting money out
and putting money out so let's reward
instead for because when somebody goes
to work
they get rewarded for how they do right
and they get a raise for doing better
and that's the way people work they work
on incentives and they work
um
that's that's the nature of humans and
uh yes uh representative Hall yeah I
just thought to Alicia when they say
they're supposed to have a plan
uh what Dave is saying is they do have a
plan they can't supposed to they're
going to submit a plan before they get
any money so we it's not like they're
going to get the money and then maybe
they'll plan it out or not so there is a
I realized that that was part of that
extra money whatever the extreme needs
grant that we put in they have to put in
a plan they have to um have in the plan
ways of evaluating and they have to
report back how it did that's in that
that's we've done that this is something
different this is so that we have a
two-pronged approach to the same problem
let's give both things the opportunity
to succeed
yeah thank you representative like I say
I'm tracking you
um let me just say this and we've said
this before as we all know we give a lot
of money to schools that have deficient
third grade reading scores okay that's
that's part of the funding mechanism
that we have in New Hampshire
and I understand that we understand you
know schools show they're struggling
with teaching reading so we want to help
them we give them money
understand that uh there are folks
myself included that wonder if that's a
perverse incentive in that it in a sense
to some people you know it's not the
intent of some folks look at it but some
people see we're giving money to schools
that have the worse they do with reading
more money you give them so I understand
the intent but there's concerns about
that what I suggested though like that's
not the intention no I'm not Dave I'm
not I'm not talking to your I'm just
trying to
set lay this out so that you'll see the
intent of this measure so I that's
separate from what yeah it's got nothing
to do with what I was talking about
right yeah so this is not about that
this is about the the impetus and the
motivation for folks like myself who
want to in addition to giving money to
schools who have deficient third grade
reading scores to let doe come up with
some sort of a formula to be determined
uh we don't need to get into the details
on that uh what we'll vote on
um soon is simply uh the notion of the
concept of an incentive Grant and if if
this comes back in some form next year
then that'll that'll uh reflect uh the
recommendation of the subcommittee and
then the whole committee so a million
dollars and we've talked about this
before uh
why is representative like is touched on
I mean why not come up with some some
sort of a formula to reward uh
achievement and I know there's that
that's contrary to the culture of a lot
of uh Academia but um as representative
like I said the the notion of rewarding
achievement
fundamentally can work
and also if school money I mean I know
we're always saying but we need to find
more money for schools here's another
million bucks fifty thousand dollars to
schools they do well so or they do
better and if if out of that if if some
school improves whatever the formula is
that we don't need you know that but if
at some point some formula is
established by Doe to reward uh
Improvement in whatever assessment is is
designated then some schools may say so
what did you do differently to improve
your your scores and uh we want to do
this we want to approve our scores too
so anyway that's that's the the essence
of it all uh yeah sure sure all right
representative Ellison uh just following
up on that uh I think it's a very
perverse argument to suggest that a
school district is going to
enhance and improve its entire
educational system by giving them fifty
thousand dollars that that that runs
that's not common sense to say that uh
the fifty thousand dollars you know what
might put a foreign language teacher
back at Pittsfield High School because
they pay so little that it might cover
the cover everyone uh but it's not going
to have an impact necessarily on the
scores uh I would then I raised this
during the testimony that this is in a
perverse way this is the opposite of
what and you understand this like the
way the NBA and the national passive and
the Major League Baseball goes so this
this particular bill would say to me if
the Golden State Warriors won as they
did they ought to get more draft choices
they should get more because they did
well we ought to give them more money
and the fact is that whole system is set
up so that the team that does the worst
can get you know they they get they get
we get the first rap Choice uh so I this
is It's a perverse way to to look at
educational change right and I do I know
website let's fill out your hand up I do
want to respond to just one of your
comments about uh this does not intend
to fix quote the entire educational
system uh
there's no pretense of doing that but I
think I think that if it is a new
opportunity to try something different
as was stated earlier that could make a
difference a a it's not going to fix an
education the system doesn't claim to
but if it can identify some approaches
that work that might be emulated anyway
uh representative Westfield sure
thank you representative Moffett
um I I feel as though we're talking
about two different completely different
bills here so if I could just bring us
back to house build 1676 my question to
you is
what we're working on right now with
this interim study are we able to make a
positive recommendation today
um in favor of this in light of the fact
that attorney Fenn mentioned that we
need to kind of offer some further
rule-making authority to the doe I just
want to make sure I understand that
please sure great great question and as
I've said earlier uh having done a
number of interim studies uh gifted
being one of them or the co-curricular
building that Diana mentioned being
another one of them the center of study
process uh when the chair or whatever
refers to build interim study some
places they think bills go there to die
and in some cases like with gifted like
with co-curricular like with these two
bills I hope we're talking about here
out of this discussion we can identify
some some ways to improve the the
language so what I would be looking for
today a uh would be a recommendation on
the on the broad concept and you know
it's not the function of an interim
study committee to come up with a formal
uh proposal because we can't we can't do
that you know the the session is ending
all we can do is make a recommendation
as to whether uh the concept uh has
value to be developed in future
legislation is that kind of answer your
question it absolutely does I would like
to make a recommendation that we do more
forward in a positive fashion with us
okay so there's a there's a motion to
move forward so so in the same emotion
your motion is to support the concept of
an incentive Grant yes representative
Moffett that is what I'm saying
okay is there a second for that I'll
second that
okay so we have a motion to support the
notion as
stated in 1676 relative to making
incentive grants for school districts
that improving certain assessment scores
but further uh representative luckis
yeah my understanding of an interim
study was to make recommendations not
just whether to move forward with the
concept but recommendations with
improvements or changes that should be
made to the original bill so if we're
trying to move something forward should
we not in that include
that we need to get a hold of doe or
whatever to put the additional language
in to allow for rule making and I mean I
thought that was the point was that we
would be
giving some specific recommendations
for improvement or change
um that's come out of our discussions
so that
whoever then can look at this when they
if they decide okay we'll go ahead and
submit a bill they can look and say okay
well the interim study said oh we need
to add additional language or we need to
make the money come out of a different
place or whatever so is that going to be
part of our
report sure
um this company has already met earlier
and from that earlier you weren't able
to be here we sent some notes out to
everybody that was a broad summary of
some of the discussion items that came
up and and that those notes are out
there
so the motion
um
that's on the table or on the floor
um supports the the broad concept no in
terms of implementing the broad concept
uh I think certainly uh when this comes
to the full committee uh and you know we
can speak to some specific ways pluses
or minuses you know in terms of
implementing the incentive Grant notion
uh
you know if it's up to the folks on the
subcommittee if if our report wants to
have some specific uh recommendation
that if a version of this is in a new
LSR next year that it reflects as an
example
um the notes that I made
not that it's part of the motion that's
on the floor but uh I would take
attorney fence comments about rules and
and giving them uh some better specific
group guidance in terms of rules for
implementation that that would be part
of
uh go go ahead you you were shaking your
head yeah that's that's that's not what
attorney Fenton was suggesting she was
suggesting it's it's it's it's simply a
a technical line that has to go into a
bill if you need the department any
Department in the executive branch to do
rulemaking you have to enable it through
through 541n that's all yeah um uh uh
attorney Fenton was suggesting not any
specific framework for rules or anything
like that that's up to the department
and it's up to how the bills laid out
currently the bill is set up the title
is called an incentive Grant the Bill's
language as as Alicia was talking about
is set up as an award so after an
outcome is achieved then a district
would get a fifty thousand dollar reward
what I've suggested is use it as a
commit competitive Grant process where
districts submit a plan so now we
actually have a black and white plan of
of what a district is going to do and
and how much that's going to cost inside
of this fifty thousand dollar you know
budget and um and and the the department
could judge those and again this would
all go it make its way through 541a into
rules
and then um and then the top whatever
the top ten or whatever the the
department concludes or was put into the
bill
um uh uh uh
applications are selected They will
receive a fifty thousand dollar Grant
and then and now you've now you've
enabled you've empowered you've been and
you've enabled the school district to um
um to to try to hit whatever Benchmark
they they put in that um in that Grant
application I agree with everything
Arthur has said that fifty thousand
dollars does not get you very far in 172
million dollar you know Manchester you
know School District uh budget
particularly when Manchester the average
kid in Manchester is performing at the
fourth percentile the governor said
yesterday that New Hampshire's public
schools are great we're top five
nationally it's just not happening
everywhere and it's not happening
happening everywhere because a lot of
the districts are so severely
underfunded and and obviously this this
these are things that we learned
through the the the the school funding
commission's uh work uh which which
absolutely I think aligns with what with
what you're suggesting that um that we
need to fund schools based on student
outcomes and I think there's an
opportunity here to do it not with um
not with the billion dollars that the
state of New Hampshire is currently
spending on on its public school
districts but with a million dollars and
we might be able to learn some things
through how the grant applications are
um are are documented judged and then
put into effect sure share a couple
things and then Melissa back to you
um what you're describing said at the
top I was intrigued by and interested in
but that's a different very different
from what this bill is about I think
Dave that would be maybe should be or
could be a separate LSR uh that takes a
different approach okay as opposed to
trying to completely turn around the
intent of the incentive Grant thing into
what you describe and also I have to say
that uh you know fifty thousand dollars
uh especially from from folks who I know
truly care about you know trying to
maximize funding for schools uh to
diminish a million dollars or fifty
thousand dollars is not making this does
not intend to fix everything but it
intends to help in in small ways that
maybe could turn into big ways so I I I
hate to hear the the idea of fifty
thousand or a million dollars being you
know basically I I think it's it's
important and I think it's I think it's
significant and I didn't say I didn't do
what you just uh suggested on that I'm
I'm just suggesting that that fifty
thousand dollars
um might be able to move the needle
further in a small District than than in
a much larger District like Manchester
so yeah so so what does that mean for
our larger District what does it mean
for our smaller districts what does it
mean for our more our better resource
districts that might have the money to
invest up front to move their needle and
then receive the you know
um you know win the prize and get it get
fifty thousand dollars back to um to to
cover their costs when they had the
resources to uh to implement that at the
beginning I'm just suggesting that some
districts don't have the resources to to
even consider doing this and and that
continues to increase the opportunity
Gap that we're seeing across our state
our students opportunity Gap that we're
seeing across our state between better
resource districts and less resource
districts we've got a million dollar
opportunity here to try to close that
Gap
by a million dollars
uh I'm sorry uh Melissa you had your
hand up and then Alicia I just I have to
say that I'm really concerned that I
continue to hear the notion that more
money equates better outcomes because
it's not always the case and we keep
talking and comparing these more
affluent areas to Manchester just
because you throw more money out of
Manchester school is not going to change
the outcome we need to take care of the
drug problems there we need to take care
of the kids there that aren't being
taken care of just in general in their
home life has nothing to do with giving
more and more money to the education
system
you're right I can believe whatever I
want more money does not solve these
issues the way the world is made is
incentive right you incentivize people
and you reward them okay kind of like
that old saying right you don't just
give the man the food you can teach them
to fish right there's there's a feeling
of goodness when you reach your goals I
get it you just want to throw more money
it doesn't work that way okay uh
representative luck is uh would like to
say something please thank you
actually I was going on in the same
direction but hopefully you'll let me
actually finish it which is that this
has been done over the country for
decades putting more and more money in
schools to get better outcomes to the
extent that in one school the judges
said that all money must be given by the
state whatever is required and that
school district built everything that
they could think of and in fact they had
more money they were trying to figure
out what to do with it and yet the
outcomes remained the same and that has
happened for decades all across the
country and I if you wanted statistics I
can give them to you because they're out
there and I have spent the summer
studying all of this to try to figure
out what we can do and I keep coming up
with this but what has worked in some
states in some times and in some places
is incentives incentives for improvement
where people are rewarded for doing
better that has worked throwing money in
the beginning has not worked and you can
see it in state after State year after
year all across the country and if you
want the statistics I'll give them to
you
thank you let me give you a specific and
Innovative motion of the floor and this
is a discussion of the motion I guess
um uh here's an example
um
and there's no mandate so I I taught at
Trinity High School for for a while and
they had a math team so if this
incentive grant program of some sort
gets into place and if some school the
larger small Richard's poor whatever if
if on their own uh somebody at that
school says let's have a math club and
we'll try to make math fun and we'll uh
we'll have a club and we'll have
activities we'll do math and so if out
of that
um some standardized math scores improve
then that would and they get a reward
then suddenly uh I think the kids would
feel great I think the school would feel
great and I think that others might look
and say okay you get fifty thousand
dollars would say can you use however
they want uh so what did you do for that
fifty thousand dollars uh you had a math
club well you know maybe we should have
a math club too so if you track them you
know I mean that's the type of
innovative outside the box thinking that
this might incentivize that could make a
difference that's just one if that helps
oh yes
Mike can I speak on this I haven't
spoken on this one yet uh we may have to
vote all right we'll just let you speak
Mr chair
I'll speak to the discussion on the
motion on the floor
so that's uh sure physical objection so
um
you know when we're looking at the the
idea of incentives that it's very
important
um that's why we had the commissioner
awarding Blue Ribbon Schools here in
this state annually
and there's a process a very specific
one that Diana was alluding to and just
recently we've asked in fact Dave was a
co-sponsor on the farm State Fair bill
which we allocated 250 000 in 541-a was
part of that but was very specific
giving the Commissioner of Agriculture
the criteria and conditions for awarding
these grants for Capital Improvement on
the state fairs we need to if we're
going to go here
um we're going to have to get in the 541
business as far as being very specific
as to what this is used for and what is
the criteria for awarding and what's the
outcome we're looking for what kind of
data you we're using how we're analyzing
data how we're collecting data how we're
using that to show Improvement
um the um the first step that I would do
here is try to work with doe and and
improve upon or support some of the uh
recognition
programs that they have in place and
rather than just trying to go with
another one I would try to add to what
they're doing to try to improve
curriculum secondly I would also work
with the recently reformed
committee for the Improvement and
assessment legislative oversight
committee which we have that meets in
another couple weeks here and I've
invited Nate green to that Nate green is
in charge the analytics over there at
doe looking at these assessment reports
which we have we do not have an analyst
over there at doe right now to help us
delve down into the specific areas that
we are assessing we're just looking at
that
top 30 000 Tower as uh thirty thousand
foot uh score which we get oh you're a
one two three or a four and you're
you're a wonderful school or one that's
not proficient well why uh where are we
on these specific questions that are
being asked to kids are we analyzing
that that no we are not they're not
doing a doe because they don't have a
staff to do it
and in working with Caitlyn and working
with Nate we've come up and there will
be an LSR it's already it's already in
the hopper
um where we're going to be looking for
in the first year 160 thousand dollars
for an analyst in the second year 145
000 we will be working with specific
schools to take these achievement test
scores look down underneath specific
topics like I mentioned like mathematics
looking at specific areas find well we
might be doing well in this category of
math but in that one we're hurting
that's where we're missing the boat but
they're not doing this on the district
levels or on the state level either we
just don't have the staff to do it and
we need to get in that business so my
recommendation would be I'd add to what
you're going because the incentives is a
great idea that we work with doe to
further improve incentive programs that
are in place but we also support the
make a recommendation to the oversight
committee which we reconstituted this
just this last year in June on it was
put together by the governor or we all
sponsored that you helped write it
where they have the responsibility for
assessment and performance Improvement
this be a wonderful topic to send to
them too as well and say hey what are we
going to do to try to improve in our
area mathematics in the state we have a
long way to climb here so incentives are
great uh but I think we got to be
specific and we've got to work with
other groups as well
um just another lsrs it's going to be
another year before we see any outcomes
we can get some outcomes right now if we
if we work a little bit more at this and
I think we're in the process of doing
that I would invite you to attend the
oversight committee I think it's on the
27th Premiere I don't have that calendar
in front of me I can get it to you I'll
get out to everybody
but that's going to be important because
we're going to have the assessment
results from 2022. it's the 28th yeah I
think 27 or 21 yeah one of the two there
where what we're doing is we're looking
at cohorts of students what they were in
their third grade what that same group
was in the fourth grade by the state and
by the schools
and seeing where we're going because we
know we still have that waterfall effect
in the middle schools where the scores
are dropping off why
we we've known that for not just as a
result of covet it's been on this day
ever since I've been on this committee
we've been dropping in and you talk to
the people at Community College they say
well 60 of our kids come in that are
remedial in mathematics of that 60
percent 50 percent never get an
associate's degree
and they waste a lot of money why well
then we work with bath Dorian over there
with the math communities program which
we had and we had 38 high schools
working that we showed Improvement but
that Grant has disappeared and a lot of
those courses are disappearing too so uh
we got to make some efforts to get
something that stays in place Dan Wolf
was very involved with the math
Community Learning Labs or Community uh
program which we have it's in statute
there's no money to support it anymore
so I would suggest that you know you you
add to your your recommendation that
incentives also be put forward to the
oversight committee and that we work
with doe in terms trying to strengthen
some of their programs that they're
currently doing and recognizing
outstanding performance and growth and
achievement that's why we have now
growth not just achievement there's some
schools that are high achieving schools
how are you going to ever measure growth
there uh and that they're doing a great
job uh you want to recognize them for
what they're doing as well uh not just
an incentive but an incentive just to
continue doing what they're doing so
there's so much out there and we also
need this analyst this analyst research
one to work with Nate so we can
understand what this and if anybody
wants to see the wording which we have
in this is going to be responsible for
um
um the academic research and Improvement
performance data analysts shall collect
and analyze assessment attitude measure
student progress evaluate program and
instructional Effectiveness guide
curriculum development and resource
allocation and promote accountability
um through and what they're that we're
going to have to make some of our
decision making is going to be have to
be data decision making based upon this
information which we never really used
the way we should so uh I would suggest
which we you strengthen that uh that
recommendation to the full committee to
incorporate some of those other avenues
where we can work
and not just Silo it in one little area
a lot a lot of stuff there and thank you
and we do have a motion on the floor and
I do have to point out as I said earlier
Caitlyn Davis actually several of us
spoke with several people informally a
doe I mentioned earlier Caitlyn had
specific ideas as to assessments to use
we've spoken to the commissioner this
language was written by Caitlin and Nate
the language you're not this language I
just read right oh yeah but not they
they did not write the uh 1676 no no no
no right right no
um so a lot of stuff they lost everyone
talked to you about uh and everybody
else later on for now it is four o'clock
before we have a take the vote of the
motion anything else that anybody wants
to add Beyond what's been said
um I'll add one thing Mike
like sure I'll add one quick thing
um uh I'm I'm probably going to vote no
on this if we're looking at the sort of
the black and white of the of the the
framework of the the interim study bill
as as it exists right now uh I think um
I could certainly be in a very different
position come the time we have a
committee vote
um on this if if there's uh maybe a
draft
um committee report because I think
along with the recommendation for or not
recommended for for future further
legislation comes two or three sentences
right
with that with the there's there's a
blue mini blurb yeah on this but if
those two or three sentences I think um
you know include some of what Rick's
talking about and maybe something that
that levels the playing field so that uh
so that some of the larger districts can
also maybe see not as as as profound a
uh uh a change and um and and and and
um have resources to be able to to do
that uh consistent with maybe programs
that are already in place right now
um you know I think I could I could take
a more favorable position
um on the from the committee
uh thank you for that and when we after
we met the first time on both of the
bills we just met on I did send notes
out to everybody and invited uh you know
further content or editions we'll try to
do the same thing here so whatever the
vote outcome here is will uh uh do that
and I'll send some notes out and and we
can um
hopefully get uh a minority not a
Minority Report but some if if you think
there's some pieces of this uh for a
subsequent LSR next term that could uh
could work better than what this is and
I think that would be very useful to
have as part of the report to the to the
full
for now we need we need an up or down on
um the motion to support the
um
motion was made by
representative Litchfield and seconded
by
um represent leckis
yay or nay yay on the concept
represent Industrial
email emotion yeah uh Professor podson
you made the second
percent of uh Bruno
representative Ellison
representative Hall no
president Muffet uh surprising about ga
all right I'll I'll work on some notes
from this and send them out to everyone
and Mr chair since you happen to be here
um do you have any sense of when the
whole
the whole committee will will come
together I know there's uh something
um
it most likely won't be till late
October
okay well what it is is that you know we
haven't met during June July August uh
or July and August and September we're
starting to pick some of this up and we
have other studies going on committee
the whole is going to be working on 1680
and we have others uh so that we're
going to deal them all in one day you
know rather than separately so we won't
be meeting until we're ready to go with
all this and there are some other
sideline type committees and commissions
working right now
um so it won't be to latter part October
uh we'll probably do it just before we
have to have the report in in November
foreign
thanks everybody for
um
27th of one
yeah there's a meeting in the mornings I
recall
alrighty
but yeah tomorrow's a big day isn't it
it's gonna be interesting
yeah
all right I I don't know if I'm all on
board on the uh
the money going back out to the uh
regarding the utility or the uh the 100
uh dollar check to individuals I I I saw
the bill come through yeah
um and I don't know who the sponsors are
but that didn't show it on the bill no
it just said it was it was rough rough
yeah yeah and so so I think there's
probably going to be some tightening up
and sound there's Scott I understand
yeah because if it was just going to go
to the individual user myself
then I'm going to go down buy a six pack
of beer and have a great no kidding yeah
and so yeah so that's not gonna no no
but also you know if there's if there's
income qualification stuff like that
um Henry and Dave don't need you you
know well I'm also concerned that here
we had a parking garage we're dealing
with yeah and we allocated not the
dollars we needed for it and and John
Graham's fake concern was that here we
got the cash
and yet we're going to bond later on and
use our bonding power up when we have
cash which we could be using
um and I'm concerned this is 60 million
dollars worth of stuff here right now
and I'm saying to myself cheapest what
about the rainy day or what about some
of our Capital costs with CTE or with uh
with all these other areas School
building Aid I'm looking at the